You have been setting up event
listeners using jQuery's on method.
Now this works really well, but
jQuery also has some convenience
methods that you can use.
Let's take a look.
This is how we would set
up an event listener for
a keypress on every input field.
We could rewrite this using jQuery's
convenience method by replacing the on
with the keypress.
And now we don't have to specify
the event type because the convenience
method implies it.
See?
Much nicer.
Looking at the keypress documentation,
you'll see jQuery point out
that the keypress function
is actually a shortcut for
the on method,
passing keypress as an argument.
It's important to know that there
aren't convenience methods for
every event type.
Take a minute to look up what methods
are available on jQuery's API site.
I have linked to the appropriate
page in the instructor notes.